hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the biden administration is backing
democrats sweeping ethics and election
reform bill
to overhaul the nation's rules for
voting and funding political campaigns
but republicans argue the package will
fuel voter fraud and take powers away
from states
arizona attorney general mark brnovich
who defended his state's election
integrity laws before the supreme court
this week
and democratic strategist mary ann marsh
weigh in on the debate over the bill
and share their different plans to
restore faith in elections
and march is women's history month fox
news at night host
shannon bream explores some of the
remarkable female figures written about
in scripture
her upcoming book titled the women of
the bible speak
the wisdom of 16 women and their lessons
for today
and opens up about her own faith plus
commentary from former arkansas governor
and fox news contributor mike huckabee
the fox news rundown is
a daily news podcast where we take a
deeper look at the stories important
to you you can subscribe on your
favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com i'm
harris faulkner i'm greg gutfeld i'm
janis dean
and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday march 3rd 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal
who can change how we vote is up for
debate before the supreme court i'm very
skeptical anyone
comes along and says we're going to
create a federal or one-size-fits-all
solution
and lawmakers are arguing over it as
well the best thing to do is to have
congress
reinstate the voting rights act and pass
hr one
i'm dave anthony we're going to take you
inside the bible
shannon bream on her new book telling
stories about women back then
that are relatable now these women face
problems even though their lives were
thousands of years ago
things that are very much real world
2021 problems
and you see how they work through them
and how they rely on faith
and i'm mike huckabee i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
last year may have been the year for
voting but this year maybe the year for
voting
laws congress is debating a massive bill
that would impact voting on a national
scale it's called hr1 or the
for the people act which senate minority
leader republican mitch mcconnell
recently slammed their bill would take
prudential questions about early voting
registration and no excuse absentee
balloting
and resolve them one way for the entire
nation they want to force all 50 states
to allow the absurd practice of ballot
harvesting
there are also multiple proposed laws in
states around the country that would
change voting rules
senate majority leader democrat chuck
schumer criticized the republican
proposals this week from the senate
floor
when you lose an election in a
democratic society
you update your party platform and
appeal to more voters
you don't change the rules to make it
harder for your opponents to vote
and this week the supreme court heard
arguments about the voting rights act
section two as it pertains to two laws
in the state of arizona
one that restricts who can gather up
your vote and turn it in for you known
as ballot harvesting
and another that required ballots cast
at the wrong precinct to be discarded
now section 2 prohibits laws that can
discriminate based on race
and the democratic national committee
sued arizona alleging these laws
violated section 2. while a federal
judge said the laws did not violate
section 2
a full panel of the 9th circuit said
they did writing that minority voters
were more likely to cast ballots at the
wrong precinct
and restricting who can collect ballots
disproportionately impacts minority
voters
who the court found are more likely to
need help turning their ballots in
it is incorrect and the dnc is
absolutely wrong
to any way imply that these laws are
racially motivated
as i said a majority of states have
similar types of statutes
and if you accept the logic of the ninth
circuit
it essentially would gut or jeopardize
every single voting integrity law in
this country
every time there's a statistical anomaly
and that just can't be correct
mark vernovich is the attorney general
in arizona and he argued for the state
before the supreme court tuesday arizona
we provide all sorts of methods to
people to exercise the franchise
you can there's no excuse absentee
ballot balloting
you can vote early we have voting
centers we have drop-off
boxes in some counties you can vote up
to 27 days for the election
so there are all sorts of ways that
people could exercise their franchise
and as just as alito pointed out is when
about 80
of people in arizona vote by mail so one
of the stats the ninth circuit hunger's
had on was
the percentage of um african-americans
versus
um white voters um that voted out a
precinct
well the reality is we're talking about
a number of about 4 000
votes out of millions cast so
we argued and we said that that was not
substantial
and you can't have courts overturning
a state's election laws every time
there's some statistical anomaly
because there may be numerous reasons
for that and unless it's significant
courts are going to be micromanaging and
getting themselves involved in
every single state selection and
basically we're going to have to
litigate every single state election law
it was literally every time there's an
election there is a proposed
new law that congress is debating i'm
sure you've heard of it it's called the
for the people act
um it would result in in broad changes
to
voting rules mandating early voting same
day registration
it also claims that it would restore the
voting rights act
um though much of that effort i think is
actually happening through um
through separate legislation but but
anyway the restoration
is is meant to sort of remedy the fact
that the supreme court
invalidated section 5 of the voting
rights act in 2013.
and that section required certain states
or jurisdictions with a history of
discrimination to get federal approval
before they alter any voting procedure
i'm wondering how you think a ruling
impacting section two which is what
you're involved in
how that will impact the debate around
voting rules and regulations
going forward with this new for the
people act
and do you think either way a court
ruling on this will light a fire under
this debate
first and foremost i do think it's
important for the u.s supreme court
to provide certainty in this area and
it's one of the reasons why we're
articulating proposing our
tests that you have to show a
substantial disparate impact
and then two you have to show causation
and you have to look at once again the
totality
of circumstances in that voting system
and so
you know that's you know the first thing
the court needs to do
now second as far as what congress may
do
i look i learned a long time ago not to
rely
on what's happening in washington dc you
know sometimes out here
i joke that washington dc is where good
ideas
go to die because the reality is that
congress can't seem to get
anything done so i think it's
problematic for anyone
that's relying on washington dc to solve
a problem
and part of the reason big part of that
reason is that
that's not what washington dc or that's
not what congress designed to do
the powers were supposed to be few and
defined and i always remind folks that
the federal government did not create
the states the states created the
federal government
after the election we had though and the
claims that were made in the 2020
election
is some uniformity um
you know a good idea it should should
there be some
rules or regulations that sort of
permeate throughout all the states
um not even just in response to what
happened in 2020 but just
for the sake moving forward of some
uniformity
the question really comes down to you
know
should someone in california be telling
arizona how to run their elections and
you know
what the constitution requires is we
want to make sure that
no one is disenfranchised that we're
protecting everyone's right to vote
but different states may have different
methods for the best way to
you know secure the integrity of that
vote and to ensure an
orderly and fair election and you know
we said what may work in some rural
state may not be different than what
works in
you know new york city and so i'm very
skeptical anyone comes along and says
we're going to create a federal or one
size fits all solution
what i instead would argue or say to use
it
the problem is is the supreme court
hasn't articulated
any tests when it comes to section two
and what we need
is for the supreme court to basically
say this is what states can do and this
is what they can do
and that way you don't have judges
basically rewriting election laws
so close to an election and i think
that's part of the problem
is when you have unelected judges
whether they're state or federal judges
and look at the states that have the
most problems those were states where
there was changes being subsequently
made
to the process of how votes were counted
extending
you know deadlines on curing ballots
accepting mail maps so
those are issues that you know the
federal law is not going to solve the
problem is that you have
judges that are creating chaos um
you know weeks into an election or even
after early balloting starting that's
the problem
are you hopeful given the majority here
on the supreme court
that the justices will side with you
some folks you know on on a more
left-leaning side
say that you know they're worried uh
that that when it comes to section two
and this debate that that you've argued
before the court that
that they're going to lose we have a
very strong case and i am very confident
in our case
i think uh i did a good job arguing the
case
and at the end of the day we didn't get
to say this but i was waiting for the
opportunity to
remind the justices that even the biden
department of justice
you know filed a letter saying that our
laws do not violate section to the
voting rights act
so i am confident that we are on the
right side
and that legally what arizona has done
is consistent with the
u.s constitution and also consistent
with the voting rights act
finally republican state lawmakers have
quite a few proposed bills in dozens of
states right now
pertaining to how we vote the
left-leaning
brennan center for justice says they are
bills proposed by republicans to
restrict
voting access what do you say to that
accusations that republicans are trying
to restrict
voting with these laws you know i i
i don't know what the legislature is
going to do or not do
not only in arizona but especially in
other states as i said i
you know there's there's an old saying
mark twain said that um
no person's life liberty or property is
safe for the legislators in session
and so it's disappointing that someone
like the brennan center would try to
make this a partisan
issue because i don't think it's a
partisan issue i think this is all about
securing the vote and making sure we
have integrity
in the process and people have
confidence in the result
period now some strongly disagree with
that like democratic strategist marianne
marsh
ever since the gutting of the voting
rights act almost eight years ago
we have seen increasing steps to
restrict people's access
to voting there isn't a voting integrity
problem there isn't a security problem
that wasn't true in 2020 and it hasn't
been true for years
but what there has been and continues to
be especially in the wake of 2020
is legislation passed by individual
states
that make it harder for people to vote
and especially people of color
that is indisputable arizona is guilty
of that in this case that they're trying
to defend
when they talk about going to all male
voting
many native americans who live in
arizona don't live on a postal route
therefore you're discriminating against
them you know
in in georgia they passed the most
restrictive
legislation ever shortening the general
election to four weeks
shortening the number of days you can
vote shortening no voting on sundays
when it everybody knows
that black voters many of them go to the
polls on sunday
after church a day most of many don't
work
and they're organized to go vote they
even put in a provision
that you can't distribute bottles of
water when you're standing in line to
vote
when you reduce the number of voting
locations
in certain districts which have been in
georgia north carolina and other places
communities of color the lines are
longer
and many people aren't able to stand in
them because they have to go to work
or they make they're on shift work and
they can't make miss a shift because
they'll lose their job and lose their
pay
so there are many many insidious ways to
to make it harder if not impossible for
people to vote
and that's un-american and undermines
our democracy
section two of the voting rights act
though was what was argued this week
before the supreme court
and many democrats are worried due to
the court's majority
about preserving section two which says
you cannot have voting laws that
discriminate based on race
and i guess the worry is that while this
may help address issues that arise
after the fact it is all that is left
after the supreme court invalidated
section 5 of the voting rights act in
2013 and that section
forced you know new voting laws to get
federal approval in jurisdictions that
had a history of discrimination
are you among those who are worried
about section
two and where the court falls here yes
absolutely and i think any
objective person who supports democracy
and voting rights is
concerned and that's why there's a push
to pass h.r 1
in congress because it includes the john
lewis voting rights act that would make
a
a federal mandate in terms of access to
voting
across the board and it while it
wouldn't take away
individual states abilities to enforce
certain regulations and others
it certainly would stop discrimination
now when you listen to some of the
questioning and the arguments you want
to feel a little optimistic but it's
very hard to feel optimistic
when you look at the current composition
of the court and
certainly john roberts role earlier
during
when he served in the reagan
administration in his opposition to
voting rights so
there's plenty of concern for everyone
the best thing to do is to have congress
reinstate the voting rights act and pass
hr one which would provide
a federal mandate for people to be able
to vote um
and have access to voting marion marsh
thank you so much for your time
you're welcome
[Music]
[Applause]
this is mike huckabee with your fox news
commentary coming up
we're about to take you back in time way
back
to a time that has been read about and
studied
for centuries in the bible
now today we're going to focus on some
people who are sometimes overlooked
shannon breme has a new book out titled
the women of the bible
speak the wisdom of 16 women and their
lessons for today
my faith is the center of my life and so
um
to dig into these stories that i've
heard growing up in church and sunday
school
and feeling like well i've got a pretty
good grasp of this to really dig into
these women's lives
i learned so much shannon dream of
course is also the host of fox news at
night on tv
and has her own podcast with a great
name
living the bream so it's really one of
those books whether
um you're a person of faith or not i
think there will be all kinds of new
things to discover as i certainly did
and i was really inspired because these
women faced problems even though their
lives were thousands of years ago
um things that are very much real world
2021 problems
and you see how they work through them
and how they rely on faith and
some of them get off track and and you
know come up with other plans that are
not in line with what god has planned
but even in that
what i love is that he was able to use
their missteps just like he can for us
now we all get off track and off path
sometimes um but there's still good that
can come from that and i saw that in
these women's stories
and what motivated you what made you say
you know women are often not the focus
of a lot of bible stories or
or books in the bible what was it that
said you know i really want to bring
these stories to life
yeah because i think there's stuff
that's so good for now
i mean it isn't just old dusty boring
fairy tales i mean these are real
stories about women's lives who
they may be overlooked sometimes but i
really you know growing up in church
and going to religious school all the
way through my undergrad and
college i was exposed to a lot of these
stories and i thought you know what a
lot of people
probably have never heard of some of
these women of course people are
familiar with
mary the mother of jesus and and maybe
queen esther
but there's so many stories here of
women who um really rose to the occasion
they found courage they found faith and
i thought
man i i love that these stories are
there but if people don't know them and
can't
sort of be challenged and encouraged by
them we need to get them out there so
you know i'm really thankful that this
is um one of the first books coming
under under fox news's
book label and i'm so glad that they
decided to tell these stories and let me
help do that
it's interesting you mentioned mary the
mother of jesus and also mary magdalene
you tell their story at the end of the
book as opposed to making them first
because those some
they may be the names that people know
the most why'd you put them last
you know we sort of work through the old
testament through to the new testament
so
it's a bit of it is chronological but
some of these women we we study them in
pairs and look at the commonalities in
their lives the common threads or
lessons that we can learn
um but it was really sort of
chronological through the bible
um but i actually you know there's a
little intro that starts the book
who is a woman from the new testament we
don't even know her name but her story
was clearly so
important that it was included in a
number of the gospels it's told multiple
times about this woman who
had this physical problem for 12 years
she had an issue of bleeding
and we knew she went from doctor to
doctor we're told when we meet her
she basically has lost everything she's
had no physical health no doctor who's
been able to solve her problem and she's
spent
everything she has looking for help and
she's been shunned
pretty much by society correct yeah i
mean exactly and that's such a great
point you bring up because
that in that time period she would have
been considered unclean so probably from
what we know about her she wouldn't have
been able to go to the markets or into
crowds to the temple
to worship her you know her faith
community she would have been pretty
much homebound
an outcast really idea yeah and there
are so many women
in this book who are outcasts but christ
reaches out to them regardless he
doesn't care about the rules of the day
or what anybody says is the right thing
to do
and in this case this woman hears about
jesus she hears about these miracles and
thinks
all right if i can just touch the hem of
this guy's garment
there's something there and i think i
can be healed so here she is going out
in a crowd where she shouldn't be
she does finally get to him touches that
garment and the bible says immediately
she was
healed but also that christ knew um
clearly he knew what was going on and he
says to one of his disciples who touched
me
now anytime he asks a question or god
ask a question in the bible you know he
knows the answer already
so he's now waiting for her and um the
disciples sort of laughed like hey
you're in this crowd everybody's
touching you
she is in fear and trembling we're told
falls before him
now she knows he could expose her that
she shouldn't even be there she is this
outcast he could have shamed her in
front of all these people what are you
doing touching me you didn't even ask
her
my help and he instead he called her
daughter which i think is the most
beautiful thing
showing everyone now that he has a crowd
with him everywhere he goes
giving her complete acceptance and he
says your faith has healed you it's made
you
whole um and he doesn't chastise or
embarrass her
and think about the desperation she's
had over these 12 years and now it's all
over
in an instant because of her faith and
i just think that that has so many
parallels and stories
and lessons for us today and just how
merciful he was
and how he really didn't and we talked
about this a lot in the new testament
section of the book
he didn't follow the rules of the day if
he saw women in need or people who were
outcasts he reached out to them
and i think he does that for all of us
today you
pair people and the women in your
stories differently
and in one of the sections you have a
free woman
compared to her slave you have a queen
paired with a prostitute i mean you're
very diverse
people that you're trying to to put
together
yeah and i think people need to know
that just like the men in the bible the
women of the bible are not sanitized and
when we see them with all their thorns
and their stories and all of their
foibles and yes i mean i thought when we
put together queen esther and rahab who
was known as the prostitute they
both were critical in moments to save
the entire nation of israel
the people of the jewish nation and i
thought i love that that's that parallel
with them their lives couldn't have been
more different but both of them were
called
to step up in this moment to have
extreme courage and to risk their own
lives
to save the entire nation the entire
jewish people so
they had that common thread and i
thought how beautiful that
that we can see uh it doesn't matter
what your background is where you come
from if you're royalty
or if you're somebody who would be
considered on the outcast infringe
and lower part of society by many people
you can still be used by god
and i love that about their two stories
you know you also
have um paired people who who lived
centuries apart they would never have
known each other
so is it just that they had a similar
experiences
yeah many of these women wouldn't have
known each other in any way but we see
that they
have um different experiences of faith i
think about
hannah and i think about miriam and both
of them are from the old testament
hannah
we see her story in that she was
childless and her husband had another
wife
which was you know the custom in that
day um who not only had
several children but she mocked and and
made fun of and cruelly taunted hannah
because she couldn't have children which
is
the desire of her heart we see that she
went to the temple every year and prayed
to the point one time where the priest
eli pulled her out and thought she was
drunk and said
you need to leave the temple and she
said no no i'm just weeping before god
i'm begging and asking him for something
what eli would later find out when she
returned with her child samuel that it
was the son she was praying for
and she had told god i will give you
this child to come back and serve you
and that's what she did with daniel she
left him with eli the priest and he went
on to serve
and to be the one who found king david
and to recognize him as the leader of
the nation of israel so
um you know she really gave up this this
child that meant
everything to her miriam the sister of
moses is the one who stood by
when you know the king and the pharaoh
had said all of the children there the
hebrew children
had to be thrown into the nile river and
killed and his parents his mother
was brave enough that she made a little
mini ark almost for him a little
thatched basket and sent miriam to put
him into the river and watch
to see what happened to him so again
miriam is there as moses
is is um you know discovered by
pharaoh's daughter
who then wants to raise him as her own
so in both cases we see these precious
sons these children are sent off to an
unknown fate but wind up in great
service to god
you wrote in your introduction for many
of us 2020 was a year filled with pain
physical financial emotional mental
and so for those readers
who had those experiences when they read
all of what these women went through
do you find it relatable
yeah i'm hoping that they'll see these
women shared common burdens they were
betrayed some of them they dealt with
jealousy they dealt with heartache and
infertility
they dealt with loss and i think that so
many of those emotions are common to
today where we feel
overwhelmed or like maybe god isn't
aware of our situation or he's not
listening he doesn't see our losses
there have been many occasions for
people like that whether you're person
of faith or if
maybe you felt drawn to that over the
last year because you've kind of felt
the end of your rope
i think people have been searching
spiritually in a lot of ways and and
looking for something much more
comforting than you know the gloom and
doom that the world has had to offer us
last year and you know people are still
very much dealing with
financial ruin or having lost a loved
one and i'm hoping that through these
pages they'll be encouraged to see
how and their deepest sorrow god was
there with these women and he lifted
them up and he
walked them through really dark valleys
and i think we all have moments like
that and certainly this last year has
really uh exacerbated that for a lot of
folks
you you quote a lot of scripture through
the book as you go through these stories
do you think that sometimes the bible
intimidates people where the language of
the bible they don't they can't quite
uh necessarily understand everything
that's that's there that
and that books like yours help people
understand better
yeah i think you're right and i
certainly hope so i think for a lot of
people if you read the traditional
english translation with that we have
the king james version that it's known
as
there are these and vows and and people
you know the sentence structure
isn't like modern english right so i do
think people get a little overwhelmed
like oh this
sounds like you know the language of the
kings and of the
royalty from the you know 1600s and
1700s and
um but the great thing is there are so
many bible translations now that are
in what we would consider modern
american english that
make it much easier to understand so a
lot of times in writing the book i would
go to different translations to see
um how it had been interpreted i don't
speak the original
greek or arabic or hebrew so those are
very helpful to me to go back and say
like hey this one sounds like
a conversation i would have now there's
one translation a lot of folks use these
days called the message and it's written
much more in a conversational tone but
trying to stay true to
the text and accurate to the bible uh at
the time it was translated and written
so i hope that this book and telling
these stories
because some of them have so many twists
and turns they would be bestseller books
uh if they were written as these
individual stories or blockbuster movies
and hopefully people would say
gosh i didn't know the bible was that
interesting or that that women were such
prominent characters
and hopefully in reading the bi reading
the book
they'll see that and it will feel more
approachable uh and more relatable to
them
at the end of each section of the pairs
of women you put study questions is that
to maybe inspire people to have bible
study type groups
yeah i mean i love study questions
myself whether you do them yourself i
mean right now i'm reading through a
book during lunch that has the questions
every day which
then kind of helps me to internalize
what i've read or apply it to myself or
figure out what it means for me
and i hope that people will do these
individually or as a group
i always get more by hearing from other
people in a group who've
studied or read and have different
perspectives i always find that to be
really helpful
and to point out things i didn't see so
i think whether you do it alone or as a
group
i hope the the questions will give you a
deeper understanding or
maybe application of what you've read
but i always enjoy
finding those in books and so i'm glad
we included them here too
the new book is the women of the bible
speak the wisdom of 16 women and their
lessons for today brand new from
shannon bream the host of fox news at
night shannon good luck with it and it
was great to talk to you thank you for
joining us
thanks you too
[Music]
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows
live swipe right for the latest fox news
radio newscasts on demand fox news radio
and the fox news app
download it today subscribe to this
podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
mike huckabee
what's on your mind as we learn from the
recent hit documentary about britney
spears ongoing conservatorship battle to
regain control of her life
abuse of this legal mechanism is a
national epidemic
in need of drastic reform the new york
times feature which was released in
early february
exposed some shocking details about
spears legal dispute with her father
who has done everything in his power to
keep control over the singer's personal
finances
since she turned 26 years old
am i the most unlikely person you'd ever
expect to be siding with britney spears
over her father well no not at all
i recognize the artistic gifts britney
has
but she should also enjoy the personal
freedom that every american adult should
experience
it's possible she might make business or
even artistic mistakes
with her life but like the rest of us
she's entitled to make decisions
for her own life so unless she's about
to commit
imminent physical harm to others or
herself
britney spears ought to be free to make
her own decisions about her life and
career
in 2019 spears case gained national
attention thanks to the free brittany
movement on social media
which highlighted the behavior of the
singer's father and other players in her
inner circle
the ongoing media interest in britney
spears legal struggle however comes
with its own curse it creates a
perception that the pop icon is a unique
victim
of a dysfunctional family corrupted by
sudden fame and wealth
sadly this is not so the enormous scope
of the
conservative tour ship abuse epidemic
goes way beyond britney spears
but it often gets ignored by mainstream
news outlets that mainly cover famed
celebrities and prominent public figures
in recent years dozens of guardianship
abuse cases have sparked
outrage in communities across america
one of the most extreme examples
of this abuse occurred in alabama or one
of the state's most generous
philanthropist
the late golden flake heiress joanne
bashinski
spent the last days of her life fighting
to protect her own estate
in what's joel blankenship the legal
counsel for the joanne bashinski estate
called
quote as predatory and exploited of a
case as i've ever seen
end quote court documents detail how
that for the better part of a year
she repeatedly requested that her
employees john mcelroy and patty
townsend
diversify her investments and they
continually ignored her request
finally after finding out that they also
unilaterally wrote themselves into her
will
bashinski was left with no other choice
but to terminate their employment
an apparent retaliation mcilroy and
townsend filed an emergency petition
alleging
that bashinski had dementia and was
unfit to handle her own estate
bashinski's personal physician based on
his own evaluation and consultations
with both a
geriatrician and neurologist found her
perfectly competent
stating clearly that she did not have
dementia
or any other psychiatric or neurological
conditions
now that didn't stop jefferson county
probate judge alan king from granting
the temporary order
and appointing greg hawley as
conservative or
of mama b's 200 million dollar plus
estate in october of 2019.
after more than a year of legal battles
the alabama supreme court finally
overturned the emergency
conservatorship back in 2020
despite the wild media frenzy around
britney spears
conservatorship abuse is a nationwide
epidemic that impacts countless u.s
seniors with very little legal recourse
available
for the conservative ease to escape it
and that's precisely why it deserves
national
bipartisan reform and a grassroots
campaign to protect the most vulnerable
members of our society
who are entrapped by it this is mike
huckabee
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for
up to the minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
new from the fox news podcast network my
name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes